[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السي
ابي عاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
واحداث وتتفاعل اخرى نبدا من رام الله
وهذه الصور المباشره بعيده اعلان عائله
الاسير الفلسطيني المحرر ماهر يونس افراجا
الاحتلال عن عقب التحقيق معه بشان شعارات
مناوئه للاحتلال
والى تل ابيب ومظاهرات حاسده فيها وفي مدن
اسرائيليه عده ضد حكومه نتنياهو التي لم
تكمل شهرها الاول في السلطه بعد
وهذه الصور تريدنا مباشره من الخرطوم بعد
اعلان من الامم المتحده تقول فيهن نحو 12
مليون سوداني بحاجه لمساعدات غذائيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
[موسيقى]
تونس وجدل الاحكام العسكريه على المدنيين
الامن يعتقل رئيس كتله الائتلاف الكرامه
على خلفيه احكام بسجن عدد من قيادات
الاحتلاف اطراف سياسيه وحكوميه تهدد وتصف
الاحكام بالانتقاميه والرئيس سعيد يشدد
على ضروره التصدي لمن يعتقدون انهم فوق
القانون
بعد الاخفاق في تحقيق اختراق باجتماع
الحلفاء في رمشتاين اوكرانيا تجدد
مطالبتها للغرب بتزويدها بدبابات ثقيله
ودور البلطيقه تطالب المانيا بتوفير
دبابات لابرد فورا لكيف روسيا تكثفه
هجومها في بخمس وجنوب اوكرانيا وتجري
تدريبات في مقاطعه موسكو تحاكي التصدي
لهجمات محتمله على المنشاه العسكريه
والاداريه
في تعقيد جديد في ملف انضمام السويد الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي تركيا تلغي زياره وزير
الدفاع السويدي على خلفيه مظاهره مناهضه
لانقر في ستوكهولم وتستدعي السفير السويدي
للاحتجاج على السماح بتنظيم المظاهره
واقدام يمنيا متطرفا على حرق المصحف
بعد يومين من اكبر مظاهرات في فرنسا خلال
عقدين مظاهرات في باريس بدعوه من منظمات
شبابيه وحزبيه للاحتجاج على مشروع ايمان
مكروه لتعديل نظام التقاعد ومجلس الوزراء
الفرنسيه يجتمع الاثنين بمناقشه مشروع
القانون المثيري للجدل
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا سياق وتداعيات اعتقال
الامن التونسي رئيس كتله ائتلاف الكرامه
على خلفيه احكام صادره من القضاء العسكري
بسجن عدد من قيادات الائتلاف فيما تعرف
بقضيه المطار لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
الى اين يذهب المشهد التونسي في ضوء احكام
القضاء العسكريه الاخيره
46% صوتوا لصالح تصعيد المعارضه
33% راوا انه لن يكون هناك تغيير بالمشهد
بينما صوت واحد وعشرون في المئه لصالح
تصعيد السلطه هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت
عبر مسحي رمزي كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله طيب مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليه
لقاءنا تتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
من تل ابيب الى حيفا وبئر السبع والقدس
الغربيه مظاهرات حاشده ضد حكومه نتنياهو
قبل اكتمال شهرها الاول في السلطه
قبل قليل تابعنا تفاعلكم بشان السياق
وتداعيات اعتقال سيف الدين مخلوف زعيم
ائتلاف الكرامه التونسي ونائب السابق في
التقرير التالي يعرض لنا حافظ مربح المشهد
بمزيد من التفاصيل ويعرض ردود فعل
المعارضه على الخطوه التي علقت عليها جبهه
الخلاص بالقول ان هناك اراده لحصد رؤوس
قاده المعارضه
هكذا صرخ المحامي والنائب السابق عن
ائتلاف الكرامه في برلمان تونس سيف الدين
مخلوف اثناء اعتقاده بعد حكم القضاء
العسكري بسجنه هو واربعه من نواب بائتلاف
الكرامه والمحامي المهدي زقربه ومنعه من
مزاوله المحاماه ل 50 سنوات
مع ذلك جبهه الخلاص المعارضه الى اتهام
السلطات بمحاوله اغتيال الحريه وهدم
الديمقراطيه بتوظيف القضاء لحصد خصومها
السياسيين على حد تعبيرها وقالت هيئه
الدفاع ان هذه الاحكام الانتقاميه جابتها
خروقات كثيره واكيده انها تمثل فضيحه
قانونيه وحقوقيه على حد تعبيرها ثم فعل
واحده تاع المطار
فيها حكم مدني والمحكمه العسكريه سمحت
لنفسها بان تنظر من جديد في القضيه خلافا
لكل مبادئ القانون وان تصدر الحكم الجائر
لاصدر
بحكم الدستور وبحكم القانون التونسي لا
يمكن ان في الجرائم العسكريه
ولا ان غابت اي تعليقات او ردود فعل رسمي
عن هذه الاحكام فان بعض انصار الرئيسي
يبررونها ويؤكدونا ان القضاء مستقل تفنيدا
للالتهامات التي طالت رئيس الجمهوريه
باستغلال القضاء العسكري لتصفيه معارضيه
كل ما كان الاحكام في صالحهم كانت القضاء
مستقل والقضاء ممتاز وعندما يكون الحكم
ضدهم يصبح القضاء غير مستقل يعني سمعت بعض
الاتهامات اصلا للقضاء العسكري ربما مش
معقول ان احنا نعتبره كل الدول تظن انه
الحكم كان قليلا على سيف الدين مخلوف بان
غزوه المطار وذلك الذي قام به اعتبارا
جريمه
القضائيه الجديده تعيد الى الواجهات اذن
بشان ما يراه معارض رئيس قيس سعيد
استخداما للقضاء العسكري في المعارك
السياسيه كما تعيد ايضا اثاره قضيه تصنيف
المواطنين امنيه تحت ما يعرف 17
دي منعهم من السفر
السبب الرئيسي لهذه القضيه يعود الى نحو
سنتين حيث جد خلاف مع رجال امن بالمطار
عندما حاول نواب ائتلاف الكرامه والمحامي
مهدي زقربه الدفاع عن حق مواطنه في السفر
منعتها شرطه الحدود من مغادره البلاد
استنادا الى ما يعرف في تونس باس 17 وهو
تصنيف سري للجدل وصفته منظمه حقوقيه
بالظالم تستخدمه وزاره الداخليه لمنع من
يشتبه فيهم من السفر دون اعلامهم مسبقا
بذلك ودون تقديم اي تفسيرات او ايضاحات في
غياب اي امكانيه للطعن في ذلك القرار حافظ
رباح الجزيره تونس
حذر رئيس حركه النهضه التونسيه راشد
الغنوشي من ان البلاد في خطر ودعا الى
حوار وطني والى وقفه جاده من حكماء تونس
التي تحتاج التوافق والتعايش دون اقصاء
كما قال اضاف الغنوشي ان الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد مصر على حكم الفرد والاستبداد
بحسب تعبيره قائلا انه لا يمكن المراهنه
على جواد خاسر واشار الى ان خطاب التهديد
والتخوين يمكن ان يتحول الى عنف مشددا على
ان حركه النهضه لم تقصي احدا من جانبا اخر
قال الغنوشي ان القضاه في تونس مهددون
وانما سماها سلطه الانقلاب توظف القضاء ضد
حركته انتقاما من المعارضين اضاف الغنوشي
ان تونس ترفض اي تدخل خارجي في شؤونها
الداخليه وقال ان الشعب التونسي اتى
بالديمقراطيه وسيسترجعها بحسب تعبير
حول هذا الموضوع تنضم الينا من تونس شيماء
عيسى القياديه بجبهه الخلاصه الوطني
المعارضه ومعنى من تونس ايضا السيد محمد
ذويب الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بكما
سنبدا معك سيد محمد ذويب
باعتقادك لماذا اقدم القضاء العسكري على
هذه الخطوه
[موسيقى]
في البدايه
على القضاء العسكري هذا من ناحيه المبدا
ولكن سعيده الكريمه هؤلاء حقيقيون الذين
يصيحون اليوم 2012
اليوم هذا من الناحيه من الناحيه الثانيه
لم تحاول حركه النهضه وائتلاف الكرامه
خلال العرشيه الفارطه تكيف هذا القانون او
الغائها او استبدالها بقانون اخر يكون
اكثر تماشيا مع المسار الديمقراطي الذي
تشهده تونس اذا من الناحيه الماديه انا
اودين هذا القانون ولكن احمل المسؤوليه
للذين صمتوا خلال العشا
لماذا اقدمت بغض النظر عن ما فعل
السياسيون لماذا اقدمت المحكمه العسكريه
على هذه الخطوه مع العلم انه معروف انه لا
يجوز
محاكمه اشخاص جرت محاكمتهم همم يعني مره
ثانيه جرت محاكمتهم في القضاء المدني
المتضررون من القضيه وزاره الداخليه
واعوالها قاموا باعاده استئناف القضيه
وهذا حق القانوني بطبيعه الحال ولكن رغم
ذلك كان يمكن ان تكون هذه القضيه على قضيه
مدنيه بطبيعه الحال ولكن اريد ان اوضح ان
الاحكام التي اصدرها المحكمه العسكريه لا
ترتقي الى جريمه ارتكبها هؤلاء الذين
دخلوا الى المطار وهو جهه تونس وصارتها
الاولى واعتدوا على الامنيين وادخلوا نوع
من
[موسيقى]
الرشاش والعنف ومارسوا ذلك الامين عموما
لم نكن نتمنى ان يحدث كل هذا ولكن انا
احمل المسؤوليه الذين حكموا صادقا ولم
يكيفوا هذا القانون مع الوضع الديمقراطي
واتمنى
ان يعيد النظر وفي غيره من القوانين
الجاهزه السيده شيماء عيسى باعتقادك ما
الهدف من خطوه المحكمه العسكريه وما
الرساله
الهدف واضح نحن يعني ما زال اسبوع على
الدور الثاني
لمهزله الانتخابات قيس سعيد وجه له الشعب
التونسي صفحه كبيره عبر المقاطعه ولا
الموبيليت بخارطه طريقه بالتالي لا بد من
رقصات بهلوانيه لابد من تقديم قرابين يعني
تتماشى مع الخطاب بالشعبه وتغذي الاحقاد
وتسترجع صراعات يعني ربما يكون لها صدا
يعني في الساحه هذه هي اليوم من ناحيه هو
اا اا البيك للمعارضه همم لكي تهتم اكثر
بهذه القضايا الحقوقيه والمحاكمات
والمحامين وغيرها وتهمل عمليه المقاومه
ومن ناحيه اخرى استرجاع معناها هذا هذه
ثنائيه بين قيس سعيد وبين النواب في حادثه
يعني نواه بقتلي في الكرامه ولكن السيده
شيماء ما الذي ما الذي دفعكم الى الاعتقاد
بان هذا الخطوه مدفوعه سياسيه همم وباهداف
سياسيه
هي المحاكمه من اصلها هي محاكمه سياسيه
اليوم في الندوه صحفيه وضحنا انها يعني
كانت فيها اخلالات عديده بالجمله حتى في
تقديم القضيه وكيف ان المحكمه العسكريه
ليس لها اختصاص في هذا وعلى فكره يعني من
قاموا بالقضيه ضد الاستاذ سيف الدين مخلوف
والاستاذ مهدي ذا جروبه احدهم في السجن
والاخر يعني يحاكم الان لانه كان في نقابه
امنيه لا حقيقه يعني هي انا قبيله الامنيه
وما تركته من بصمه في تشدير يعني الشيطان
الشيطان السياسيين والشيطان قصيره وغيرها
استعملها الخطاب الشعبي استعملها قيس سعيد
يعني في في تاسيس فرديته الانقلابيه
واليوم ها نحن محاصرون يعني بكل هذا
المسار على قانوني اليوم يعني في العالم
عمرها ما صارت ناس همم تتحكم ثم نعيده
محاكمتها هذه هي
قلب العمليه السياسيه قلب العمليه
الانتقاميه قلب الظلم وهذا هو يعني
الانقلاب الغاشم الذي اخرجنا من دوله
القانون الى دوله الفوضى اليوم نحن نعيش
في فوزه نعيشوا فيه السيد محمد زويب يعني
هناك
المعارضه التونسيه توجه همم
الاتهام مباشره للسلطه بانها هي من يقف
وراء تحريك هذه القضيه في القضاء العسكري
لتصفيه حسابات مع المعارضين
الحديث عن ان قيس سعيد يمسك بالقضاء هذا
كلام مردود على اصحابه قيس عيد فشله فشل
ذريعا في في تاسيس لقضاء مستقل وهذه احد
النقاط التي تسببت في كل هذه المشاكل في
البلاد القضاء
سيف الدين مخلوف او مهدي تجربه او بعض
المواد الذين حتى شعب التونسي لا يعرفهم
لو كان قيس سعيد كما يريد يقول لك فتح
ملفات اخرى تبين حركه النهضه وهي ملفات
ثابته القضاء افلت من قيس عيد فشل يحل هذه
المعده القضائيه بطبيعه الحال هناك حرك
سياسي في البلد كنت اتمنى ان لا يتم
اللجوء الى القضاء العسكري واللجوء الى
القضاء العسكري بطبيعاته هو كميه ضد
الرئيس قيس سعيد ولكن ايضا الحديث عن ان
الوضع السياسي بطبيعه الحال هذه المعارضه
تقريبا 25 حزب الى خمس مجموعات لم يستطيع
منذ اسبوع ان يجمعوا الا
من نقاط قوه الصعيد هي نقيه كثير المعارضه
لو ان هذه الاحكام مدفوعه السياسيه لكان
جرى همم تصفيه الحسابات مع شخصيات اهم من
الشخصيات التي اعتقلت بالامس
في مقال يعني فشل القيسي سعيد فعلا فعلا
هو فاشل في كل شيء حتى بعد يعني سحقه
للمنظومه القضائيه حتى بعد افراغه القضاء
يعني من السلطه وجعله وظيفه حتى بعد همم
سبعه وخمسون قاضيا وقاضيا حتى بعد هاتكه
اعراض القاضيه حتى بعد يعني كل هذه
الجرائم هو فاشل بالفعل القضاء يقاوم
ولهذا التجات السلطه الى القضاء العسكري
لانها هي تحديدا من اختصاصات يعني موكله
للسلطه فالقضاء العسكري اليوم هو هذه
اليدين
الان نسال عن التداعيات القانونيه
والسياسيه لما حدث باعتقادك اي تداعيات
سيكون لذلك
اليوم الاستاذ سيف
الدين كم مرتين اليوم جبهه الخلاص ترفض
هذا وتواصلوا يعني
مقاومه هذا العبث وهذا الانتقام اليوم فما
لحمه فما تضامن كبير مع الكرامه والاستاذ
مهدي زقروبه بصفه مبدئيه لانه الحمدوله
يعني الخطاب الشعبي صحيح ذهب ببعض العقول
ولكن
سعيد عبر تطويعه للقضاء عبر السياسيين
وعبر تدميره للبلد لن يفلحها وسيف شل وسير
يرحل
شيماء عيسى القياديه بجبهه الخلاصه
الوطنيه المعارضه وشكرا للسيد محمد
زويب الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من تونس
[موسيقى]
تدريبات في مقاطعه موسكو بهدف السد
الهجمات الجويه على البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه والصناعيه والاداريه المهمه
اعلان لافته من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وسط
تقارير متزايده بشان استعداد اوكرانيا لشن
هجوم مضاد واسع النطاق زمن ذلك مع تكثيف
القوات الروسيه هجومها في باخ موت وجنوبي
اوكرانيا
اخفاق المجتمعين في قاعده رمشتاين في
امداد اوكرانيا بدبابات ثقيله اعربت كييف
عن اسسها لما سمته تردد الغرب بينما حثت
دول البلطيق برلين على تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات فورا
مقطع فيديو وحيد من موسكو يقول ناشره هذه
الصور انها منظومه
للدفاع الجوي الروسيه
في العاصمه موسكو مقارنه الصور تقول ان
المنظومه نشرت على سطح وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه لكن تقارير تفيد بان القوات
الروسيه نشرت هذه المنظومه ايضا على عدد
من المواقع الحساسه في العاصمه بدايه فان
هذه المنظومه مخصصه لاسقاط صواريخ كروز
والقنابل الموجهه والمسيرات يستطيع نظام
الرادار فيها رصد الاهداف على بعد 30 كلم
يرصد 20 هدفا ويشتبك مع اربعه في الوقت
نفسه في الاعلانات الرسميه تكشف وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه عن اجراء تدريبات لوحدات
الدفاع الجوي تحاكي التدريبات صدها جماعه
مفترضه على المنشات صناعيه وعسكريه
استخدمت في التدريبات هذه المنظمات اس 3
للدفاع الجوي الروسيه الشهيره هل هي مجرد
وتدريبات بروتينيه ام ثمه قلاق مات رفض
الكرملين الافصاح عما اذا كانت البلاد
تتحضر لهجمات المحتمله سالته وكاله
الانباء الفرنسيه فاحل الامر الى وزاره
الدفاع التي لم ترد على السؤال هذا
الفيديو نشره مستشار وزير الداخليه
الاوكراني ويقول انه صور قبل اسبوعين يشير
الفيديو وفقا المسؤول الاوكرانيه الى مضاد
للطائرات بالقرب من منزل الرئيس الروسي في
التحليل يقول المتابعون العسكريون ان
روسيا اما انها قلقه من هجمات اوكرانيه
على العاصمه او ان في الامر بوادر ازمه
داخليه على شكل انقلاب عسكري على الرئيس
الروسي كل هذه المعلومات والتحليلات لا
تخرج عن سياق الدعم الغربي لكيف الاحاديث
المتواتره كذلك عن ان القوات الاخرانيه
تتحضر لشنها هجمات في العمق الروسي بحلول
الربيع تتهم موسكو القوات الاوكرانيه
بالوقوف وراءها هجمات بطائرات مسيره على
البنيه التحتيه العسكريه في عمق وادي
الروسيه لا تهديدات الرسميه اوكرانيه حتى
الان بشنها هجمات شرقيه الحدود الا ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تقول انها تعتبر جزيره
القرم جزء من اراضيها ولن تتوقف عن
استهداف القوات الروسيه فيها تلك جزيره
تسيطر عليها روسيا منذ عام 2014 ويعتبر
الهجوم الاوكراني وعليها تحولا في
استراتيجيه القوات الاوكرانيه من الدفاع
الى الهجوم السؤال الان هل ستسمع صفارات
الانذار في العاصمه الروسيه كما سمعت في
نظيرتها الاكرانيه يوم الرابع والعشرين من
فبراير الماضي
انضم الينا من كياف سير هيكوزان المستشار
في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ورئيس المركز
الاوكراني للامن والتعاون ومعنى من موسكو
يفجاني في دروف عضو مجلس ادومه الروسي
مرحبا بكما سيدي اف جيني فودروف ماذا تقول
لنا هذه التدريبات الروسيه والمحاكاه على
التصدي لهجمات ضد منشات عسكريه وصناعيه
واداريه في موسكو
المتحده قد توصل الى اوكرانيا اسلحه بعيده
المدى قد تصل الى موسكو بالطبع يجب ان
ندرس امكانيات الدفاع ضد هذه الهجمات
الولايات المتحده تقوم بغرض طفولي ليس
لديهما خبره بالدفاع عن اراضيهم لذلك هم
يقومون بغلط قد يؤدي الى وقوعهم الى فخ ان
الخبراء لدينا
يقولون ما الذي سيحدث اذا وجهت روسيا
استحتها الى المدن الامريكيه كما حدث هذا
سابقا والكل
يرد على هذا السؤال لان همم
عمليات الروسيه الان تدمر النظام العالمي
احادي القطبيه وان ضربات روسيه لامريكا هي
تهديد حقيقي واي تهديد لروسيا يجعلنا
نستعد لهذا
سوزان هل هذه الاسلحه التي تتسلمها
اوكرانيا بالفعل قادره على الوصول الى
موسكو وهل اصلا لدى السلطات الاوكرانيه
هذه النيه
لم تضرب ولا تخطط لضرب اي منشات خارج
الاراضي الاوكرانيه كل الضربات وكل
الاسلحه الاوكرانيه موجهه لتحرير الاراضي
الاوكرانيه من الاحتلال بما فيها القرم
وهذا شيء واضح اما تدريبات روسيا
همم بسبب امور داخليه في روسيا لان
العقوبات والاوضاع الصعبه في روسيا
هذا يؤدي الى تضارب في نظام الحكم قد يؤدي
الى تضاربات او تفجيرات
وقد يكون هناك تدمير في البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه في روسيا ولكن همم اوكرانيا ليست
متورطه في هذا ولا تريد استخدام اي اسلحه
ضد اي منشات خارج الحدود الاوكرانيه
نفس الوقت كانت هناك ايضا تدريبات ومحاكاه
في قياس على من جانب الجيش الاوكراني
والقوات الاوكرانيه على التصدي لهجمات على
العاصمه ماذا تتوقع السلطات في المرحله
المقبله السلطات الاوكرانيه
بتوجيه معداتهم وقوتهم العسكريه الى
الجبهات
والقوات الاوكرانيات تدمر الكثير من هذه
الفرق والفرق التكتيكيه وتفسد الخطط
الروسيه
بتصعيد الاوضاع في المعارك لذلك كل
التقنيات وكل التدريبات موجهه للدفاع عن
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وهديمه العدو على
الارض الاوكرانيه
خارجيه الدول البلطيق مجددا المانيا
لتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات لبرد رغم اخفاق
وزراء دفاع عنيته الامس في الاتفاق على
هذا الامر
اغنيه
الدول الغربيه
هذا شيء سليم لان روسيا حتى الان
تقوم بعمليه عسكريه وتستخدم اقل من واحد
بالمئه من قدرتها العسكريه لذلك روسيا من
المستحيل ان تهدم لذلك السؤال هنا من
المهزوم اذا قامت اوروبا وامريكا بتصعيدات
وهذا ايضا يخص
المانيا عندها قد ايه
تحول الى الكثير من الجبهات قد نضرب باريس
او برلين سوف نضرب اي مواقع تهدد اراضينا
حسب القوانين الدوليه
اوكرانيا كم منطقه كدوله لم تكن موجوده في
اتفاقات ما بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
لذلك خروجها من الاتحاد
السوفيتي كان غير قانونيه وهذا انفصال غير
همم قانوني وهذا انفصال يسمح لنا بان
نحارب هذه المرحله التاريخيه يعني التي
تحتاج ربما الى
مساحات وقت او ساعه من اجل النقاش والرد
سيد سير هيكوزان هل طويت صفحه دبابات
لابرد في هذه المرحله ام ما زالت اوكرانيا
مصره على الحصول عليها رغم كل
الخلافات حول هذا الامر
شروطنا وطلباتنا لم تتغير ولقد حددناها
منذ نصف سنه وقدمنا هذا لشركاء من قبل
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيا والدبابات اللي
برده غيرها
المتواجد لدى شركه الغربيين يجب ان تقدم
هذه الدبابات لاوكرانيا وسوف نستلمها بغض
النظر عن تهديدات روسيا والان نسمع هذه
الحديث التهديدي من قبل الطرفه الروسي
عندما يذكر ان همم
روسيا تستخدم التهديدات النوويه للمره ال
20 وهذا في الواقع يجعلها لا تعترف على
بحدود الدوله لها
الامتناع الالماني عن تسليم هذه الدبابات
حتى الان وراء ذلك الامر وان بشكل غير
رسمي
بالت الولايات المتحده معدات عسكريه معينه
لكم
لديها
بالاساليب بالاساليب والقنوات الدبلوماسيه
لتسريع هذه العمليه بالطبعه العمليه ليست
سريعه كما نريد ولكننا نتذكر كيف كانت
المانيا بطيئه في تقديم معدات الدفاع
الجوي والمدرعات ولكن في النهايه كل هذه
المعدات هي موجوده الان في الاراضي
والمواقع الاوكرانيه او في الطريق ونفس
الشيء سوف نمر به للاستلام للاستلام
الدبابات الدبابات ستصل بغض النظر عن
الطماطم في هذا شكرا لكم
المركز الاوكراني للامن والتعاون من
امتياز وشكرا للسيد فرجاني عضو مجلس
الدمرسي ضيف لناصر
[موسيقى]
اعلنت تركيا عن الغاء زياره كانت مقرره
لوزير الدفاع السويدي الى انقره يوم
الجمعه المقبل جاء ذلك على خلفيه ما وصفه
وزير الدفاع التركي خلصي اكار بتقاع
السويد في مواجهه استفزازات انصار حزب
العمال الكردستاني واعطائها ترخيصا
لسياسيا يمنيا متطرف لحرق المصحف الشريف
امام سفاره التركيه في ستوكهولم وكانت
تركيا قد استدعت السفير السويدي لديها
للاحتجاج على تلك الاحداث التي يتوقع ان
تزيد من تعقيد مساعد السويد للانضمام الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي
هنا سويد وهنا يسمع الغضب التركي
اخر الاسبوع هذا ما قرره الاتراك
لم تتخذ اي اجراء بشان تلك الافعال
الحقيره والمثيره لشمزاز التي ارتكب ضد
بلدنا ورئيسنا رغم مطالبتنا اياهم بذلك
بالتالي لم تعد تلك الزياره التي كان من
المقرر ان يقوم بها وزير الدفاع السويدي
الى انقره في السابع والعشرين من الشهر
الجاري ذات معنى فلذلك الغناء
يشير اكار الى تحركات جماعات كرديه
المنوئه لانقر ونيت معا على الاراضي
السويديه
ومما اثار الحلقه التركيه ايضا ترخيص
الشرطه السويديه لمظاهره الامام السفاره
التركيه في ستوكهولم احرق خلالها ناشط
يمني متطرف نسخه من المصحف الشريف
[موسيقى]
بعضها اثار احتجاجات مضاده عنيفه
جرائم الكراهيه ليست حريه تعبير يقول وزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود تشاو شغله في حريه
التعبير هو تبرير الذي تسوقه السلطات
السويديه لترخيصها مظاهرات على اراضيها
ومع ذلك يصف وزير الخارجيه السويدي
الاستفزازات المعاليه للاسلام بانها مروعه
وطبعا طبعا
جونسون فيحرص على بياني ان علاقه بلاده مع
تركيا مهمه للغايه لكنه لا يشير الى
التاثيرات المحتمله للازمه الاخيره على
مساعد دوله الاسكندنافيه للانضمام الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي ما زال الاتراك يشددون على
ضروره تنفيذ الالتزامات الوارده في
المذكره الثلاثيه الموقعه في مدريد في
يونيو الماضي بين تركيا والسويد وفنلندا
تنص المذكره على تسليم اشخاص تعتبرهم
تركيا ارهابيين وعلى حظر عمل احزاب
وتنظمات تدرجها على قوائم الارهاب
انها اوفت بكل تعاهدات التي قدمتها لانقره
فيما يتعلق بالانضمام لناتوب ولذلك ينبغي
فيما ترى اي يعجل الاتراك بالتصديق على
تلك العضويه التي تنشدها فنلندا ايضا لكن
تركيا تعتقد ان السويد على الاخص تحتاج
لعمل المزيد حتى تزول عنها التحفظات واذا
كانت مساله اللحاق بركب الناتو في الاساس
معقده مع تمسك الاتراك بمقتضيات امنهم
القومي فالان يبدو ان ما يصدر من اعراض
السويد من استفزازات كما تسميها انقره او
قاعه انتكاستا بهذا المسار
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا حيث تواصلت الاحتجاجات الرافده
لمشروع الحكومه الهادي لتعديل نظام
التقاعد فبعد يومين على اكبر مظاهرات
تشهدها فرنسا خلال العشرين عاما الاخيره
خرجت مظاهره في باريس دعت اليها جمعيه
للشباب رفعت شعارات مناهضه للرئيس
ايمانويل وسياسته الاجتماعيه واكد
المتظاهرون انهم لن يتراجعوا عن رفضهم
التعديل الذي تريد الحكومه فرضه على نظام
التقاعد
مره اخرى يتحرك الشارع الفرنسي ضد مشروع
اصلاح نظام التقاعد
هذه المره على التعبئه الطابع الشبان
هؤلاء يخشونه
وضعهم الهش ويسد الافاق امامهم
[موسيقى]
عن نفسي ايضا
على العمل حتى سن الخامسه والستين واظن ان
لا احد سيكون في صحه جيده عندما يتقاعد في
ذلك السن
اللافتات والشعارات ترجمه غضب المحتجين
على سياسه الرئيس مانويل ماكرون
الاجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
وقد لحظ في هذه المظاهره حضور لافته
لاسحاب الستره الصفراء الذين زعزعوا
الفتره الاولى للرئيس مكرون
اصحاب السترات الصفراء كانوا دائما
موجودين دخلوا بيوتهم لانه في الديمقراطيه
الفرنسيه عندما لا تكون راضيا يفقعون عينك
نحن هنا لمواصله نضالنا وهذا استفتاء على
سياسه مكرون
بدبيك يا كابتن هذه المظاهره دعمها بشكل
لافد حزب فرنسا الابيه الخصم السياسي
لمكرون واشد معارضيه ويبدو انه كسب الرهان
من خلال هذه المظاهره لكي يكون احد قاده
تحريك الشارع ضد سياسه الحكومه
الاصلاح لانه غير عادل ومبني على الاكاذيب
نعرف جيدا انه لاعز في نظام التقاعد وكل
ما يريده ماكرون وهو تاخيره سن التقاعد
لكي يحصلوا على علاوه منخفضه ولكي يمول
الى فقط صناديق التقاعد الخاصه
مظاهرات اخرى سيارتها منظمات شبانيه
مدعومه من حزب فرنسا الابيا ضد التغيرات
التي تريده السلطات ادخالها على نظام
التقاعد وخصوصا ارجائه الى سن الرابعه
والستين وترى في ذلك سياسه غير اجتماعيه
الا ان الحكومه لا تبدو حتى الان مستعده
للتراجع اما تسميه الصحه نور الدين بوزيان
الجزيره باريس
انضموا الينا من باريس الدكتور محسن يوسف
عضو نقابه الكونفدراليه ديمقراطيه للشغل
وحسب فرنسا الابياء المعارض مرحبا بك
دكتور محسن الحكومه الفرنسيه تقول ان عدم
تمرير هذا التعديل في سن التقاعد سيؤدي
الى انهيار نظام التقاعد برمته بالتالي هل
من الحكمه هذا الرفض الواسع
لمشروع الحكومه
[موسيقى]
وشكرا لقناه الجزيره على هذه الصداقه همم
خطاب الحكومه هو خطاب سياسي لبيرالي تمويه
مبني على الكذب ويسعى الى تدخين مشكله
العجز همم
لاظهار ان هناك ضروره ملحها لهذا الاصلاح
وهذا شيء لا نتفق به لماذا لان نظام تقاعد
ليس مهددا وجميع سيناريوهات المجلس
التوجيهي لنظام تقاعد لك
ويثير على ان هذا الصندوق سيكون يعني في
متوازنا من الناحيه الماديه هذا من جهه
الجهه الثانيه هذا الصندوق الذي يعني
يتنبا يتنبا همم
همم
تنبؤات يعني غالبا ما تكون تنبؤات
لبيراليه ونحن لا نثق بها لماذا لا نثق
بها لان النفس الصندوق محسن هذه ليست فقط
الحكومه حتى المؤسسات الماليه الدوليه
تقول نفس الشيء واصلا بقيه الدول
الاوروبيه ايضا عدلت من سن التقاعد ورفعته
بسبب هذا العجز
همم يعني سيدتي نفس الصندوق يعني اللي هو
معروف المجلس توجيهي للنظام تقاعد سنبا من
10 سنوات مضت على انه سيكون هناك عجل في
2022 فاذا به نفس الصندوق يعني في تقرير
الماضي
اشاره ليس لعجز بل يعني بل يعني اشار لي
فائض بقيمه ثلاثه فاصله جوج مليار مليار
يورو في سنه 2022
لا يمكن ان نقول بانه يعني حتى لان هذا
الصندوق فيه عده سيناريوهات اكيد يتكلم عن
بعض العيش في سنوات المقبله لكن سرعان ما
هي ما سوف يعني
تتدارك لكن اتركيني سيدتي اتكلم عن الشيء
الحقيقي ما هو السبب وراء هذا النظام يعني
النظام
السبب منه وراء ذلك فهو مدون في البرنامج
برنامج توازن واستقرار
الاقتصادي التي بعثت يعني ارسلته حكومه
منيال منيال ماكرون الليبراليه الى
بروكسيل في السيف الماضي هذا البرنامج
يشير على ان سياسه تخفيض الضرائب على
الشركات سيتم تداركها بتنفيذ اصلاحات
هيكليه في العديد من المجالات من بينها
نظام التقاعد هذا ما لا يقال وهذا لي هذا
ما يقلد ذلك الوقت
معنا في السابق همم في السابق كانت هناك
معارضات لرفع السن التقاعد ومع ذلك جره
تمرير هذا الامر ما الذي يختلف عليه الامر
هذه المره
رفع يعني بغض النظر عن رفع يعني همم الى
سن 64 فهناك فتره تمديد يعني المساهمات
التي هي ستكون من 42 43 سنه في هذه في هذه
المره بالذات يعني الدول الاوروبيه عامه
وفرنسا خاصه تعرف ازمه اقتصادي مهمه يعني
هي ازمه اقتصاديه تعمق يعني تعمق من ازمه
غلاء المعيشه ومن ازمه همم ومن همم يعني
من هذه الازمات التي تضر بها التي تضر
بشكل كبير بالمواطن الفرنسي الضعيف هذا
يعني لكل هذه
اكثر من ذلك انت تتكلمين سيدتي عن الدول
التي لها تاخذ في 67 سنه لان الحكومه
الليبراليه الفرنسيه لا تنوي ان تقف الى
هذا الحد الى 64 سنه فانها تنتظر ان
تمريره هذا تمريره يعني هذا المشروع لكي
تمر بعد ذلك اعطيك يعني بعض الاحصائيات
التي انتهى وقتنا الدكتور محسن يوسف عضو
نقابه الكونفدراليه ديمقراطيه للشغل وحزب
فرنسا الابيه المعارض ضيفنا من باريس شكرا
جزيلا لك
الاضرابات التي تشهدها فرنسا تنديدا
لمشروع تعديل نظام التقاعد ليست الا جزء
من مشهد متكامل الاقتصاد على وقع الازمه
فاضافه الى تداعيات الحرب في اوكرانيا فان
قضايا تكاليف المعيشه وسلم الاجور
والمعاشات التقاعديه ومستوى التضخم تقلق
الشارع الفرنسي في ظل توقعات باستمرار
تراجع النمو الاقتصادي
2018 اتضح ان فرنسا تعيش واقعا اقتصاديا
متازما بدل لاحقا انه كان يسير نحو الاسوا
كانت تلك الاحتجاجات وتمديدا بارتفاع سعر
الوقود وتكاليف المعيشه ثم ارتفع سقف
مطالبها الى الدعوه لاسقاط اصلاحات ضريبيه
راى فيها كثير من الفرنسيه للطبقه العامله
وامتيازات للطبقه الغنيه
لاحقا لكن اسبابها لم تكن الا عود كبريت
قابل للاشتعال في اي لحظه حتى حين فاز
مانويل ماكرون بولايه الرئاسيه الثانيه في
انتخابات ابريل 2022 كان وضع الاقتصاد
الفرنسي غير مطمئن تاكد ذلك من بيانات
البنك المركزي الفرنسي في نهايه ذلك العام
فقد توقع ان يتبطا النمو الاقتصادي في
البلاد بدرجه كبيره عام 2023 جراء ازمه
الطاقه والتضخم 10 توقعته ايضا
تراجع نمو الناتج المحلي الاجمالي الى صفر
فاصل ثلاثه في المئه بعد ما كان في حدود
2.6% خلال العام الماضي
مصاعب الاقتصاد الفرنسيه جعلت مؤسسه
التصنيف الائتمان
تخفض نظرتها المستقبليه للجداره
الائتمانيه لفرنسا الى سلبيه بدلا من
مستقره
وقالت ان تراجع المرونه والسلامه الماليه
فرنسا راجع لوقود الاقتصاد لفتره طويله
وضعف الموازنه وتاخر اجنده الاصلاح
الحكوميه واحده من اهم جبهات الاصلاح هذه
كانت نظام التقاعد فوفقا لتوقعات مجلس
توجيه نظام التقاعد الفرنسي الصادره في
سبتمبر الماضي فان نظام التقاعد سينهار
بشكل طفيف وتدريجي بين عامي 2023 و 2027
جاءت خطه الاصلاح الحكوميه ببنود اهمها
رفع السن القانونيه للتقاعد ومره اخرى
الشارع يقولوننا للمره الاولى منذ 12 عاما
ظهرت النقابات الرئيسيه الثمان في فرنسا
ضمن جبهه موحده وشنت سلسله اضرابات لمنع
الحكومه من تمرير خطتها
تجادل النقابات بان هناك وسائل اخرى
يمكنها ضمان استمرار النظام المعاشات
التقاعديه مثل فرد ضرائب على فاحشيه
الثراء وزياده مساهمه اصحاب العمل او
مساهمه اصحاب المعاشات الميسوريين
تصطدم خيارات ماكرون وحكمته بمخاوف العمال
والاقتصاد الفرنسي يترنح تحت ضغوط التضخم
وارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه
وتداعيات الحرب في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
يوصلوا ومحتاجون اسرائيليون التدفق الى
الميادين في مدن تل ابيب وبئر السبع وحيف
والقدس الغربيه للتظاهري ضد حكومه اقصى
اليمين برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو وتشهد هذه
الميادين منذ ثلاثه اسابيع مظاهرات دعت
اليها احزاب المعارضه ومنظمات المجتمع
المدني وحركته جوده الحكم متهمه اختلافا
اليمين الحاكم بالانقلاب على النظامين
القضائي والقانوني لتبرئه ساحه قادته
المتهمين والمدانيين بتهم تشمل الفساد
وتبييض الاموال
قالت وسائل اعلام برازيليه ان الرئيس
البرازيلي لولا دا سيلفا اقال قائد الجيش
الجنرال جوليو سيزر دي ارودا ونقلت وكاله
رويترز انه تم تعيينه الجنرال توماس ميغيل
بيفه قائد الجيش في جنوب شرق البلاد وكان
رئيس البرازيلي قد قال ان اجهزه المخابرات
فشلت في الثامن من يناير عندما اقتحم
انصار الرئيس السابق مباني حكوميه في
العاصمه
عاد نحو 200 الف لاجئ سوداني من جنوب
السودان واثيوبيا الى محافظات اقليم النيل
الازرق وتواجه السلطات المحليه في محافظه
الكرمك السودانيه الحدوديه مع اثيوبيا
عجزا في توفير مستلزمات حياه اللاجئين
العائدين الى المحافظه مراسل الجزيره وصل
الى معسكر دويه في محليه الكرمك ورصد
اوضاع اللاجئين العائدين الى بلادهم
ظروف الحياه في معسكر دويا في محافظه
الكرك الحدوديه مع اثيوبيا ليست بالرقه
حتى لو اشرقت الشمس
اسره زينب عادت لتويها طوعا الى هذه
الربوع بعد سنوات طويله من اللجوء في
الجانب الاثيوبي
عربي
ناكل الايادي
العيال هناك
ياكله
الناس هنا ينتظرون الفرجه وحسب
اما عائشه ورفيقتها فيتخبدن مشاقه الذهاب
والعوده لمسافات طويله للحصول على ما
ينهيك اجسادهن قبل ان يروينا عطش باقي
افراد اسرهن
في البيت
يستقبل هذا المعسكر يوميا وسرا جديدا من
اللاجئين العائدين من اثيوبيا
حياتهم الجديده يبدا من تحت الاشجار لمن
يريد ان يسمع استغاثتهم
2021 حتى الان ما في دكتور نهائي دكتور في
واحد مدرب اسعافات الاوليه يعني
تبدو سلطات في محافظه القرموك عاجزه عن
توفير مستلزمات حياه العائدين الى
المحافظه
كل الخيرين وكل المنظمات تغيير معانا في
انه نقدر نوفر بيئه مناسبه للعايدين في
مناطقم ليستقروا يعني تستمر عمليه
الطرق الواعره الرابطه بين محافظات
الاقليم هي واحده من التحديات التي تواجه
تقديم الخدمه الانسانيه للعائدين
فبعد سنوات من المعاناه والحرمان في رحله
دامت عقودا يواجه هؤلاء ديارهم واقعا لا
يقل له مراره في ظل عجز السلطات عن توفير
الحد الادنى من الخدمه حيث الجميع الجزيره
محافظه الكرنك الازرق
نبقى في السودان وتحذيرات جديده من الوضع
الانساني الذي يتدهور بشكل متسارع ربما من
شهر الى اخر اين تزداد المعالاء بحسب
برنامج الغذاء العالمي فان اكثر المناطق
حاجه للغذاء هي اقليم دارفور وكوردوفان
وشرق السودان تشير والتقديرات الى ان خمسه
عشره مليون و 800 الف شخص اين نحو ثلث
سكان السودان يحتاجون الى مساعدات انسانيه
وغذائيه في تقرير الاحدث يقول مكتب تنسيقي
شؤون المساعدات الانسانيه بالسودان التابع
للامم المتحده انه يخطط هذا العام لتقديم
المساعدات لاكثر من اثني عشر مليون سوداني
ووفقا » اوصلت المنظمات والانسانيه الاكثر
من تسعه ملايين من الاشخاص الاكثر ضعوفا
في جميع انحاء السودان شكلا من اشكال
المساعدات الانسانيه في عام 2002 وعشرين
وطبيعه الحال تتاثر بالازمات الانسانيه
الفئات الاكثر ضعوفا ومن ثم يقول برنامج
الغذاء العالمي فان نحو ثلاثه ملايين طفل
سوداني يعانون سوء التغذيه
الحديث عن اعلى مستوى للاحتياجات خلال
عقدا من الزمن في السودان يدفعنا لتساؤل
عن اسباب وسياق الازمه الانسانيه
المتفاقمه ونقص الغذاء الحاد يشير مكتوب
منسق منسقه شؤون الانسانيه الامم الا ان
النزاعاعه وزياده مخاطر حمايه المدنيين
والتدهور الاقتصادي والاخطار الطبيعيه
واستمرار تفشل الامراض يفاقم هذه
الاحتياجات بالاضافه الى ذلك يقول المكتب
حدثت طفرات غير مسبوقه في الانعدام الحاد
للامن الغذائي بسبب فترات الجفاف وتذبذب
الامطار وزياده التضخم في اسعار الاغذيه
والسلع الاخرى وما تزال نسب التضخم في
السودان عند مستويات تصنف ضمن الاعلى على
مستوى العالم بسبب مشاكل مركبه مرتبطه
بتراجع السعر جنيه كما تشهد البلاد وفره
النقد الاجنبي يرفع كلفه الاستيراد ويحمل
المستهلك النهائي الفروق في اسعار الصرف
عاد عن ارتفاع الاسعار عالميا ولاسيما في
الوقود والغذاء حول هذا الموضوع ينضم
الينا من الخرطوم الدكتور ابراهيم الدخيري
وزير زراعه السابق ومدير المنظمات العربيه
لتنميه الزراعيه دكتور ابراهيم الدخيري
مرحبا بك ما خطوره الوضع
الكرام
اااه التقارير المعتمده حتى الان هو تقرير
التصنيف المرحله
التي التي تصدره الوزارات المانيه وهيئات
الامم المتحده المتخصصه الدبليوبيه في
برنامج الغذاء العالمي وبرنامج همم
الفاو اللي هو البرنامج الغزال العالمي
والبرنامج همم
الفاو يعني واليونيسيف هذا التقرير صدر في
شهر واحد همم الحالي ويشير الى ان
المتاثرين بحالات همم عدم الامن الغذائي
هم تقريبا سبعه وتسعه من 10 مليون في
المرحله الثالثه وتعتبر هي مرحله الازمات
همم ويصنف ذلك من بعد هذه المرحله هناك
مرحله
مرحله الصعوبات ومرحله المجاعه وحقيقه
بنيت على هذه الاحصاءات وهذا التقرير
وثيقتين الوثيقه الاولى هي وثيقه
الاحتياجات الانسانيه
ووثيقه الاستجابه لهذه الاحتياجات
الانسانيه بعمل جماعي فيه اطراف المجموعه
الدوليه والحكومه السودانيه هذا هو المقدر
حقيقه اشاره له التقرير من ان هناك صعوبات
حقيقه هذا التقرير التصنيف المرحله يعتمد
على حزمه من المعلومات او مجموعه من
المعلومات تشير او جزء منها له علاقه همم
الانفينيشن او
زياده الاسعار بالصوره المضطرده هناك همم
حسب علمي انه في شهر اثنين القادم ستكون
هناك مرحله اخرى من جمع المعلومات لمتابعه
الحاله طبعا الوضع الان همم في همم تقلبات
الاسعار
هل يمكن الروكون فقط الى المجتمع الدولي
والمنظمات الانسانيه في تقديم المساعدات
ام ان الامور يجب ان تاخذ منحا اخر
الصعوبات الاقتصاديه طبعا بالتاكيد مسؤوله
منها الدوله ولكن ايضا هناك تقرير اخر
يشير الى همم حاله همم الانتاج العام لهذا
الموسم همم ليس كما ورد في التقرير ولكن
همم المعلومات التي جمعت والتحليل الاولي
وعلى لسان وزير الزراعه يتحدث عن انه
مستويات الانتاج همم في المتوسط في بعض
المناطق اعلى من المتوسط في المتاح من
الغذاء يعني موجود هذه المعالجات حزمه
المعالجات يعني همم
الحمايه الاجتماعيه مطلوبه وتوفير الدوله
مع المجتمع الدولي فليس هناك همم عذر
للحكومه القائمه او عذر للمجتمع الدولي
المطلوب هو متابعه هذه الحاله همم لا
يختلفوا الناس عن الاحصاءات والتقارير
يعني التقرير اوتشيها يختلف عن تقرير اخر
للمجتمع الدولي والحكومه السودانيه هذا
الخلاف ينبغي ان لا يسير يعني المهيم هو
متابعه الحاله لايجاد ال- ال- ال-
المعالجات المطلوبه وانا افتكر الوسيقتين
وثيقه الاحتياطي احتياجات الانسانيه
ووسيقه الاستجابه هناك بانه تجمع جهود
الشركاء جميعا الحكومه من جهه والمجتمع
الدولي حتى تقدم يعني للمتاثيرين
والمتابعه الحالات حتى لا تكون هناك يعني
اشكالات كبيره يواجهها
المتاثرين يعني
السابق ومدير المنظمه العربيه للتنميه
الزراعيه من الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
بعد ساعات بعد سنوات من المعاناه تعود
الامور الى طبيعتها وتلتقي العائلات
ويحتفلوا الناس بالعام الجديد نتحدث هنا
عن مدينه موهان الصينيه التي يستعد سكانها
للاحتفال براس السنه القمريه هذه المدينه
شهدت في نهايه العام 2019
الى سوق الازهر التي زنت بالمصابيح الحمر
وازهار
تتذكر بائعه ازهار اوقات صعبه
والامل كل الامل ان نتجوز جميعا اللحظات
الصعبه للوباء ويعود الجميع للاحتفال
بمناسباتهم السعيده دمتم بخير شكرا
لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]